I wanted to start by saying I moderated
the Rousseau panel at comic-con and I
want to thank you for sending in the
video that you did for this movie okay
got it yep just want to start with that
so I guess I'm going to start with the
most important question and it's gonna
be for you um do you feel like you post
too much on Instagram I I'm really
prolific on it and I think I have to
rein it in now I have an account with
one photo in it I think yes exactly I
tried I just I just I yeah nope it's
about Stefan and be like hey yeah that's
our business so jumping into why I get
to talk to you guys today I want to
start by saying congrats on the movie
super fast pace thriller like I really
enjoyed that it just never slows down
from the moment it starts was it that
way on the page or was it only when you
like saw the finished movie where you
were able to sort of see oh wow this is
really fast uh it was that way on the
page but discusses that way on the page
doesn't mean it's gonna that be that way
Hawaiian screaming there's there's
levels of each for each stage of making
a film but in reading it you can tell
that it's supposed to be this type of
movie for sure yeah yeah I mean it
definitely moved on the page but
obviously Lake chadwick said you never
know that's really in the hands of the
director and the producers and what
happens in an edit and they did a
fantastic job
it doesn't relent one of the things I
liked is that another thing is that
these just it's not good versus evil
there's a lot of gray in this movie can
you sort of talk about that aspect that
the characters are very
multi-dimensional if you will I think
it's something that again I think it was
it was in the original read it was
enhanced in the rewrite I I think we we
search for it you know in terms of the
casting in terms of you know just the
character development and so every stage
I felt like that was something that
Brian
you know push for that he tried to dig
out of out of the story I dig out of all
of us and the fact that you're saying
you see it is a testament to it yeah I
think life isn't black and white in that
way you know I think people are
complicated I think the police force is
a complicated thing and I love that you
end up empathizing with the people that
you think you're supposed to not
empathize with I think it forces you to
ask all sorts of questions
it really doesn't go for the low hanging
fruit of just making a traditional cop
thriller it's it gets into the morality
of what it is to be a human and and I
add the depth which makes it much more
interesting how brutal is it really to
spend a long time shooting night shoots
it's painful it's like like I saw it's
when I say painfully it sounds like I'm
exaggerating but when that Sun comes up
and when it's the first night you're
like actually the first night is tough
but after like four or five nights in a
row and then when you're on your day off
when you still can't get off the
schedule and you because you have to go
back to it that's when it sort of hits
home that it's like this is gonna be
real real real test like so you know it
takes months to get up for me it took
months to get over shooting at night
yeah I was gonna say what is that
because if I fly to New York sometimes I
can mess with you yeah yeah let alone
like spending that long shooting night
so what is there a secret to actually
flipping your body clock or is it just
painful and that's it I think some
people can do it but yeah I I'm really
light-sensitive if it's light I'm awake
you know it's and you can black out a
room but you know but you're aware of
like our curtains on it no not after you
do it for two weeks nothing nothing
works yeah you nothing you take works
but no I'm serious I'm just being a
couple
like switch up I think what you and I
are quite aware of like the energy of
people around when you're on that drive
back to your hotel or wherever you're
saying and you see the commuters
energetic and up like you feel that
right it's kind of it's brutal you just
get through which we did talk a little
bit about a lot of people who enjoy
movies don't really realize what it
takes to put together a really good
action set piece and the time commitment
can you sort of share like which of
these which of the action sequences in
the film were you know maybe a challenge
and can you sort of talk about the
making of one of them I always say all
of them were a challenge
for instance the freezer the freezer
yeah exactly
we were actually shooting in a row in a
row in the whole Meatpacking but for ten
hours yeah crew had like optic and it
was raining and so so you're going from
being in the freezing cold with actual
meat hanging some some real meat some
fake meat hanging yeah to being outside
in the cold and going back and forth
people getting sick you know all the day
so just that while you're doing the
action you know doing these guns
sequences was difficult all the running
scripts going off that you have to avoid
where the explosions are happening yeah
like that was yeah like it we think
about how many takes you're doing that
like just running down one alley you
know you might have to run sprint down
that alley and avoid trash cans and
trucks you know 22 times you know you
may do that sprint 22 times in one night
I remember those one where we had to we
had to run across the road and then we
had to run what into what looked like a
train station the steps down except oh
yeah there weren't steps so they were
just crash mat so you're the only thing
that I dive onto it then Chadwick it's
pretty funny think about that and
suddenly someone else is like a load of
cops come and dive on top of us and it's
all right yeah it's that one that was a
funny so you're saying that making
movies is not always glamorous I would
say it is almost never it's not
before I run at a time something I'm
very excited for it is the Marvel
animated what if uh can you have you
recorded anything for that I what can
you use people
I can't tease a damn thing
I have record a song but they're not
gonna really tell you well you know
Betty come on man
oh I mean you know me boom the thing
about that is as one of my favorite
comics when I was growing up like the
old version of what could have happened
so anyway um I got already got to stop
I'm just gonna say congrats on this
movie I hope it does really well for the
both of you thank you man